yeah welcome to this broadcast I hope
I'm life yeah guys give me a quick
feedback if I'm really live and it's
working fine yeah would be good good to
know okay so let's see if I can get some
good blitz games in um this is really a
rare case i have not played a single
game of chess today I did lots of
teaching but I did not play a game so I
hope that I can yeah start not feeling
too rusty there yeah in my life give me
a quick feedback place in the chat yep
I'm on so cool let's get going and see
if I can get a five minute game five
minute gaming okay i'm getting a have a
seat going for our 5-minute yeah seekers
wrong it's the pool system yeah any of
you on who watched my simultaneous
display on saturday two days ago anybody
on watch that yeah i really got my butt
handed to me it was really really really
tough event I don't get a game yet
that's kind of weird oh now I get one
goodnight mister tom okay let's see get
a queen's gambit here okay yeah now he's
got the big decision to make okay it's
getting the real goes in going and then
playing this line with Queenie for check
that's a simple solution to the rosin
for people who don't want to study the
the big theoretical lines o queen to d6
that's a rare move they normally play
age six and it seems that his idea is to
play 94 maybe III 94 Bishop f4 night xe3
whom you want that's may be possible
okay let's just dig yeah it is hard to
follow the games they are simply 20
games is quite a quite a bit and yeah it
it jumps between game and game all the
time definitely they all play this stuff
Bishop d7 am I making a mistake here or
something I don't know hey Bishop d7 I
never see that in a GM game but I get
that in blitz all the time Bishop d7
yeah I have to switch it quits which
games quickly if I don't do that I'll
lose everything on time it's just very
very difficult I could have taken d 5 by
the way [ __ ] distracted me a bit but
this is still a nice position I think
yeah so I'm just going to develop him
and ask him what he's doing about this
c7 point yeah okay maybe rook c8 and
then a knight move but still looks
better for why this position yeah look
FC one
mm yeah maybe has Bishop g4 where it's
not it's not helping him that much I
always will have this pressure on the on
the C file I wonder if Quincy five as a
move okay not sure what is what is
movies now I think rook c8
um I don't think that making the mouse
visible is possible maybe the way we
broadcast at the moment it's definitely
not possible but it's something that we
might make work yeah okay I think we
should be five here simply to check a
form you can move the night but I have
play against the upon here anyway
yeah i was thinking i will get this get
this pawn down do I get the pawn mmm not
easily
Queen a five maybe Queen 85 rook e8
Queen system no you can ask it was tough
I mean my opponents really played well i
mean i don't know maybe I played badly i
didn't i didn't analyze the game
afterwards but I felt that I simply had
opponents who played very well and I
mean I wonder thing but not very very
clearly something like 12 to eight or 11
and a half to eight and a half or
something like that so no no way
comparable to the First Samuel wherever
one where one or games besides one there
was one draw but yeah the big difference
was that in Saturday's event there were
many games that simply were far beyond
the opening stage so there were no quick
wins or something yeah it will difficult
time now to save his pawns i think i
think i'm going to win one of the pawns
don't see how it keeps this stuff ah
yeah interesting so Bishop a for rue
Kade I still have queen before well I'd
say I think I can do it right
yeah i'm just taking the pawn
yeah the point is a point as a pawn very
important concept in chess do I want to
play Queen before you are not maybe
Quincy five that looks good yeah and the
First Samuel the first stimuli could
have won our games but yeah it was
really a completely different thing that
last Saturday okay so it's trying for
counter player and let's see how to how
to play maybe here trying to trade some
stuff okay it's got Bishop chief form
whom I wanted to take on on g6 but
that's a bad idea okay I'm gladly I'm
just training stuff I have an extra pawn
here and I have one more minute on the
clock yeah the dissimilar was tough
there was some really really good player
than that and also um there was one game
where I played one of my my students and
I really have to have to ask him about
that he's a bit bit too strong actually
and why now you're doing the sim you
thing and why why now I don't know and I
don't understand the question it's it's
just an event that icc is doing the
similar master and i'm glad to
participate I think it's quite quite a
nice nice event gives a many players
opportunity to play against them um
entire rated player okay it tries to
night d 6 too okay let's see if I can
activate my queen here maybe queen up to
F
okay 96mm I wonder there's some way to
avoid that I can get the Queen tear for
any way that doesn't look too bad now if
he trades it's very nice and it's not
that he has a huge counterplay okay
let's just play this end game now I
control efore and he is not controlling
e5 that's very important okay yeah i
think i can just pile up on the g file I
could play 97 but it wasn't so great I
think that does look rather reliable
here this is way to win and yeah why I
gave away the pawn it wasn't a good idea
but ok it's it's a it's a time when
let's see Luke g6 or something yeah it's
a time when I didn't there was a fork
okay maybe maybe there was a fork I
might have missed that okay next game
against beggar okay so we got a name let
smart in dumbo huh that's a teammate of
mine in the in the Belgium leak um let's
see what too smart and play you think he
plays a classical we display night of
three okay so yeah he's a wizar
grandmaster he's a grandmaster nowadays
but he still has the i am in there maybe
never bothered to the ICC to to tell
tell them that his GM now so
he's a grandmaster with about 2,500
yellow I'm just playing a normal Bogle
Indian setup where I've angling for
quick f5 trying rook f6 g6 this kind of
very crude attack but it is dangerous
as it happened so the crew detects are
often very dangerous ok I can go to h6
rg6 that's both interesting I go to h6
yeah okay night f8 and I can take night
tix is six it's very often the one idea
yeah this is how Allah position type is
not easy for why to play especially
especially in blitz yeah my thoughts on
Wesley so being forfeited a game in the
US Championships um yeah it's a it's a
very very uncommon thing to happen
really um and I'm very very surprising
that you would have a top player like
Wesley so I'm doing this this is no
taking during during a game I never
heard of any of that it's really really
unusual but I have to think about the
game here briefly um c 5 hmm that's true
key
he might place his six and can close my
diagonal
I take twice and take with the night he
has Quincy five a queen f5 at the end i
know i don't know maybe then 96 might be
okay tricky business yeah i thought i
thought it was quite weird that he is
taking those those notes and i
understand that it was something that
came in was pretty harmless yeah stuff
like I know don't I know don't get into
John shower or be focused or stuff like
that it's pretty harmless nothing that
really is kind of he wasn't I mean he
wasn't cheating or anything like that it
wasn't unethical or whatever it was just
it was just something that it's kind of
unusual and I think it was totally am it
was totally okay that they did they
forfeited him it's a rule violation and
it was very clear that the arbiter want
him more than more than once and if you
are want two times you add you have
really have to stop I mean there is no
way around it it doesn't matter if you
got number whatever you still have to
stop and well he didn't for some obscure
reason I mean okay said that he used
them a piece of paper instead of writing
on his score sheet but it's still a very
weird way to to handle things okay um
that's a very dangerous position
forgot to play
wow that's very tricky very tricky
position yeah there were things going on
now with his family and then stuff I
really don't know I didn't didn't read
at Bishop before in this position what
would you've played after that there
should be six on what hmm well um I
couldn't take on a three and finish flow
because of mate there was a eight was
hanging um yeah now he's trading trading
this bishop or at least he tries to hmm
ok I have to have to play it simple now
I had Bishop before yeah right now I
didn't do that that would have been much
better I guess right ok it's not a not a
bad bad position i guess i can go night
b3 bishop is seven though
27 maybe as 94 if I don't know my rook
is a bit off side thats it's really a
problem the offside the offside rook on
h8 age six sorry yeah I only read a
little bit about this family business
that is going on there with the Wesley
so I can only hope that he has some good
that he has some people that he that he
can trust and that really am a good for
his yeah that's that dead really am yeah
I good advisors let's say and yeah I
don't know maybe it's not a bad idea to
ask you mr. Singh field about some
advice I don't know every I'm in
opposition to to say something there ok
c 6 if he takes a tick f3 at the end or
not don't quite see the problem here
probably goes Queen to h5 and don't I
don't know Queen d6 I take twice take a
3 and T I'm threatening rook g2 and
Queen f3
and 94 is in the in the mix it looks
like a good position actually King edge
1 i'm jumping in he has bishop II one of
course and what now is there some tactic
look g2 not possible how do i do
something here it looks nice look aged
six maybe maybe I can prepare age six
here with Queen f6 I don't know what
it's doing actually okay maybe here
don't want to trade queens
okay can take f2 but at the end and
checkmate it look at force also also in
that's just look hanging I can I cannot
take their I can take I can do this
though that took me like a million of
years okay i'm slow i'm just slow rusty
yeah i don't know i can i can do both
Luke age six was still I'm taking this
now
I've got five seconds come on Martin
give up hey I'm your teammate you don't
don't play on time with the Rope down
can you believe that
I offered me a draw okay they made me
didn't know that that that it's me okay
so what happened to my 2500 rating yeah
i'm currently lower because the videos
that are currently on my channel
released today yesterday they are from
like i recorded them like one or two
weeks ago so there's always some kind of
some kind of delay between the release
and and stuff okay playing snuba here
from Germany that's a frequent opponent
they sometimes tend to get into time
travel against him at least this time is
playing a somewhat more active opening
he normally is one of those guys who
place a London system and then just
shuffles around doing nothing so I'm
glad that this is not happening here
okay let's see
um there's a question here by i'll crush
i crush him and about the sicilian
Kalashnikovs this is an opening that is
suitable for someone who wants a more
strategic approach yes indeed it is i
think it's one of the sicilian lines
that that suit the more strategically in
kind player it's not them um it's not
something that I would call um like
boring or anything but it is a is a line
that is more strategic in nature than
let's say the night off or so the
highest rated player that I've defeated
in tournament chess the highest rated
player that I have won against in
tournament chess is some Grandmaster
Mekhi gurevich at the time it was 2600
his highest rating was 2700 he was
number five in the world at one point I
was very proud of that game I was very
nice very nice game but I still believe
that at the at the day when we played
that he had a hangover and wasn't
completely on one hundred percent
strength Nakamura played the Scotch
gambit yes that I claimed is dubious um
this yeah well the Scots the Scotch
gambar this is the start of this opening
there are some there are some lines
there of course some lines are good
sometimes are worse and I had a game
where someone played a sub variation
that really is dubious what nakamura
played is actually quite okay of course
I mean he's not playing any trashy line
so this is something that can be
recommended in the opening that he
played yesterday at least as a nice
surprise weapon
yeah I'm not talking much about this
game just trying to be solid and not
lose on time um I can say welcome to
this video yeah I can what is this guy
doing I don't I don't really understand
it f3 and stuff but okay I he wants to
wants to reposition himself Bishop to F
to a book about the Queens gambit yeah
there are there are plenty plenty of
books there's something in particular
that you think about like a like for
black for white something something very
general there are there are many books
on the subject yeah he couldn't really
keep the sea for porn um let's see I
don't know how to I want to win this
pawn there may be Queen 85 year he
cannot play see form I'm supporting the
a porn that looks nice yeah a book about
the Queen's guys really they're really
really a lot lots of books if I go see
for how does he keep the pawn rook be
one at chicks III that doesn't look good
yeah so look p 8 or what I guess can
also play a 3 it's also quite good let's
push a 3 it's no reason not to okay okay
look we ate for Ruby 5
the Matt Matthew settler book is really
good yeah it is very good and so kind of
okay it is outdated in terms of concrete
lines but settlers general explanations
are really excellent so it's something
to still be it's still worth worth
looking at this book okay let's cover
them someone writes I was one game from
a GM norm um not really would have been
nice would have been nice I mean okay
yeah if I would have won theoretically
speaking against Landerman last year
would have been in a very good position
but I wouldn't have it wasn't it wasn't
like I wouldn't have scored the actual
norm it would have been a very good
chance though very good opportunity um
so let's let's push things him and then
take b6 and queen bee to I was thinking
those pawns are strong
yeah and he resigned that was a nice one
very very clear victory and sometimes
the struggling against the sky okay um
yeah this um yeah here's a question
about the 0 Zurich sorry Zurich 1952
book by Bronstein yes it's it's a
classic it's really a really a classic
book one of the tournament great
tournament books it's it's quite nice
it's quite nice I mean we have to always
keep it look look at it he put it into
perspective it was written obviously am
I don't know what it was it written
around that time I think it was released
not too long after the tournament and
this is quite a long time ago Bronstein
some um annotations we were fine but of
course it's not the current not like
what you would expect from a nowadays
book there are quite a number of
mistakes and and and and evaluations
that are a bit outdated but it's still a
very very very decent book of course so
we got the triangle variation here let's
develop him so yeah many people say that
this is one of their favorite chess
books Zurich tournament book it is
indeed very nice and I looked at it a
bit when I was when I was younger it's
also simply my what you have to see is
that this is tournament they are Zurich
1953 it was one of those old-time
candidate tournaments where there were
tons of players yeah they had I don't
know 30-something rounds i'm not i'm
really not sure about the precise number
but it was some guy i mean an enormous
enormous figure 30 rounds or so when i'm
just allowing a nasty check there
hmm the check there what is this it
looks that looks funny mmm okay Queens
do I go Quincy 3 or not dad's cannot
move the king but it's also it's still a
nice position even with Queens traded
yeah the book does not cover all of the
games but the thing is there's simply a
huge wealth of games to choose from
there so they have to be some good ones
they're simply too many too many too
many games there so there are really a
quite a number of classic games there is
this famous cut off game where
sacrifices the house out of this Kings
Indian position with the King hunt and
so on there are there are many great
games as some Petrosian Petrosian
exchange sacrifices and and and stuff
like that so many many cool games there
is also a book about this tournament by
night off which is regarded as very good
as well but many many many people but I
never never got around to look at that
one okay so do i take there or do i have
something better i wonder i can go to e7
maybe not to e5 but to e7 or is there
are some drawback that i don't see it at
the moment it seems that i just wind the
pawn
yeah I just win the porn i think the
jeep on you can play g3 but no not
really I looks awkward the question if I
was good at math in school um if you
want to know if you need to be good at
math to be a decent chess player I don't
think so I mean I was pretty ok but
nothing nothing great ok so how do i do
that if i go can I go see five years
Rookie seven though I take g4 twice I
can take it with I can click with the
bishop point takes you for ok let's take
it I don't want to take want to take too
much time oh wow I didn't expect that
move ok
let's reposition this to e5 then that
was a really great square
okay see 5 or g for both looks good
really yeah where are you going now with
this night
hmm I think people who are good at math
usually should have some kind of some
kind of talent for chess but it's
nothing that is the total yeah something
that is completely related or clearly
related all of the time Luke g1 Bishop
g7 g5 takes rook takes rook g8 ha have I
screwed this up maybe I did I didn't
play that well not at all yeah Kings
Indian book from 2004 added is probably
outdated a bit but it depends especially
if it can if it contains some strategic
advice it it might might be useful there
are books for this book for example by
Galaga that is from the early 2000s
which is pretty decent no I did not meet
email user Dima not sure when he died
but it must be some years ago ya know
i'm i'm promoting my poor Nia he didn't
he didn't prevent that
yep i'm approaching 2400 again yeah
chess is a lot about pattern and and
recognizing similarities and so on this
might also be the case in in math yeah
the Gallagher book is pretty okay it's
absolutely okay it's a bit outdated but
it's still very usable yeah that's a
question can a club player benefit from
looking at things that is um that is
some a bit um above their level um it
depends I think it depends a little bit
on your character if you are very easily
frustrated yeah like okay you do an
exercise and another one and another one
and you fail at every exercise then I
don't know if it's a great idea but it
um it is if you don't if you are not
easily frustrated it can be an idea to
do study some stuff that is a bit above
your level on paper at least um
especially if it is not like exercises
but explanations I think you can benefit
from from high level stuff there also
it's never really a bad idea to try to
widen your horizon let's say and look at
some new things um as a question what's
my bed will cards and reach the magic
2900 if he wants he will yes
okay so this guy's playing it in a very
simple way there with e4 which does not
mean bad i mean just pretty simple i
think i think one one one thing is that
with this question with Magnus cars
reading is that what what he actually
lacks a bit I think he does not have a
very very yeah I know it sounds harsh
with caruana but he doesn't have a very
serious challenger at the moment maybe
caruana if he gets more more stable or
so but he doesn't have someone who
really pushes him to the limits and if
he would head that I think he definitely
yes okay for example for example Casper
Casper oven Cal pavia they played a ton
of matches those five matches from 1984
to nineteen ninety those six years in
those six years they they really really
really pushed pushed each other to new
new levels that weren't um yeah that
weren't possible they weren't possible
before especially Karpov became a much
more aggressive more versatile player
yeah of course Greece shook neram
welcome where they're all strong but
there is no one that I think is really
pushing Magnus to the to the utmost in
terms of yeah if you if you look at this
this is not comparable to cup of
kasparov for example okay hmm i was i
was thinking about rook d8 but of course
he has this rugby sevens
hmm yeah that was stupid played this too
quickly so look here can I just play
would be eight it's quite passive okay
I'm trying to approach with my king if
he goes rook d7 I go King f88 I hope
that works it's rather passive but if I
can kick him out there with the rook
okay so that wasn't a move that I was
fearing so much
yeah I mean what is he doing there he
wants wow so he's saying that on king d
8 equals 95
hmm and then Bishop Bishop if eight
really what kind of guys that set a new
account know that that's a very very
hard were very very for me a kind of
unhuman way to play but okay maybe he
just is that good letting all pieces
hang here in a way maybe I can play
whoopsie and Roxy a droopy 795
wow it's got a point B 5 here in this
position
hmm
Wow ap is playing that excellently e6
Knight f6 almost made I don't don't see
any way out of this 96 maybe maybe I can
get in 96 now Wow
maybe I get this Luke kicked out but he
might play something funky he does
what is it what is this guy doing yeah
it's really really amazing check
checking the seven Bishop e8 and back
it's probably not stab at a care what
can I do I'm getting this piece back but
know that that's the one okay at least
is making some mistakes otherwise it
would have been really kind of uncanny
this looks that looks bad but i think i
think i have chances to draw maybe maybe
not maybe not actually and i am I can
play g4 there's no way no way to defend
him problem
hmm how does he win him I don't know
King f7 I don't see when I think it's a
draw can offer him a draw I offered him
a draw and now he took it I think it's a
draw yeah someone is mentioning ye as a
as a challenge yes certainly this is a
very substantial talent they're
definitely at the 15 year old I think
he's 15 right it's really impressive
2700 and he's really playing the kind of
amateur chest kind of a complete chance
nothing very single-minded so quite
quite good quite good definitely um okay
yeah I don't really analyze much
afterwards the games in in this formant
i'm playing playing more okay i'm trying
something funky against his Dutch and I
get something funky it isn't this kind
of risky for him let's see i can try to
exploit the light squares iam
hmm okay yeah I understand that's kind
of f4 is tricky huh mmm I don't like to
trade much but Jay I probably have to I
can I can try a play night off there is
no k-factor boosting while he's writing
know once you're about 2400 to the key
factors always 10 so it's absolutely not
it does not matter all the years or
whatever if if you are over 2,400 well
if you have been once over 2,500 UK
factor as always 10 so this change in K
factor was only relevant for for the
very much relevant for the this junior
players who get their get get a new
fresh rating and that we have had some
kind of some funny some funny cases
where people gained tons of points and
in in one list okay so he wants to go to
f4 here this guy I guess yeah not much
that I can do about that I have to trade
this with with knight to e to later um
studying end games instead of tactics
hmm i don't know i mean if you study
tactics you usually also practice your
end game a little bit because end games
is a lot about calculating the k-factor
home the k-factor is this is a
mathematical factor that is some used in
the calculation of the of the elo
ratings um and it is it is some the
factor that is decided it decides how
quickly you gain or lose points so if
you
have a high factor which is the case for
lower rated people and indent and and
juniors you lose more points per game
depending on your result while if you
are higher rated um you only lose 10
points for example I am rated above 2400
and I have a k factor of 10 so if I win
a game against someone who is my rating
I win exactly five points um I just
blundered this pawn that's not good okay
how much do you study compared to
playing I don't play much and I don't
study much simply because I have no time
I'm teaching most of the time or i am
busy writing producing videos and so on
I'm more of a chess teacher than then a
player okay I'm trying to get one of the
pawns back and i think i do right Knight
a5 or bishop I don't know what's better
on g4 actually g4 is awesome yep and if
you if you want an information how much
should you in general or anybody should
study in comparison to playing yeah both
is very very important you're getting
practical experience is very important
so play as much as you as you are able
to and also try to study much it's both
very important really um yeah there's a
question just teaching chess hood hood
the game of the teacher um i don't know
i think in general hmm i don't think you
can can can make a very clear judgment
there I think it's probably not very
beneficial as Nigel short set to do much
teaching of beginner
us because then you you might well you
you kind of only or your use more to
think in terms that how a beginner would
think about chess maybe this is indeed
not very helpful but I mostly teach
intermediate players so I have not
experienced that myself and in general
while you're teaching chest you're also
thinking about the game so it makes you
it helps that job connected connected to
it yeah okay this is a tricky position
here we have equal material and I'm
trying to catch his bishop here where is
this Bishop going okay so he tries for a
counter counter check my thing is I want
to get the Knight to f5 and prove that
this night is stronger than its bishop I
hope I'm succeeding with that idea and
I'd want to trade a rook here to make
sure that on the ephah I'm not getting
into trouble
yeah let's put it to a 5 i'm not sure if
h5 may be a symbol sorry is a move maybe
it is could have played King Ditu yeah
now h5 is probably in there so let's
let's go I go to h2
okay hmm he might sacrifice the exchange
so I'm going to prevent that just to be
sure okay how he has this movement and
now Bishop over to c7 so I couldn't
really prevent the exchange second
Bishop c7 Bishop f4 is a move or is an
idea let's let's do that anyway him if
he if he sex then he sex not nothing
that I can do okay maybe g-form no takes
on g4 yeah but this way this way I'm
actually keeping keeping the material I
Bishop g5 nights still good still good
for white so I cannot go f4 here but
King here
let's try to trade one look okay I have
to watch out for for the time the gaseum
of memorial the gas stream of memorial
will be covered on the icc i will also
do a life where i will do one of the
live broadcasts actually on sunday
looking forward to that i'm going to
meet up there with Timo garea the very
enterprising American player who
recently played the US Championships
very very colorful guy and interesting
player I will also do some coverage of
the tournament on my channel probably
like game of the day or something not
sure yeah it's enjoyed sent game and
here I'm promoting yeah so resigns yeah
the US Championships very nice
tournament yeah and there was yeah there
was doesn't mention about this guy guy
your sniggle itza never heard about him
but it seems that he that he cheated at
this open then I think it wasn't Dubai
was it to boy he wanted and then the
Persian Gulf yeah that amazing you have
people cheating with smartphones
remarkable really but great that day
that they called him and they really
should get in some severe punishment
there I'm not sure what is facing a
couple of years of been I guess okay um
what do I do here the exchange share
Kings Indian exchange don't see that too
often I've played it a bit myself
tv1 what yeah that must be must be some
kind of mouse club it's not terrible I
mean position is still fairly fairly
equal ish so let's get stuff out yes I'm
planning I'm thinking about doing those
some did doing those serious again the
middle game end game and so on it's been
it's been a while since I did this but
it was enjoyable and I will do this ok
so here in this game i tried to use the
dark squares see if i can trade bishops
and maybe get the night to before it
would be great so Bishop to c5 is the
idea and he's blocking this ok so night
here and he may be placed night be three
interesting hmm what do we had set up ok
if I go look dat he has see however
wow what a strange position okay I'm
going to play this move which looks
completely ugly but I don't see how I
can reorganize someone says I just
started to play chess what's the best
way to start yeah I would say if you
play online play some play some somewhat
longer time control words don't play
blitz all the time it's okay to play a
bit of blitz that's not really something
that's going to hurt your game a lot if
you play some blitz chess but make sure
to get get mostly rapid time control
games in you have 30 30 minutes or so
you can play blitz for fun but don't
make it your main your main um yeah main
pastime try to focus on somewhat longer
time control games okay this is a funny
position here i am hoping that Knight f6
is doing something against his rook yes
I was thinking Knight f6 for Bishop g7
he has Knight b6 now
oh ok Knight b6 yes you live as a
possible
I don't really see a great way to Plan C
hi this really really a problem but at
least that would break the fifth-ranked
let's do this and try to regroup pre
probably won't take but in case it does
i have a pre move rookie five maybe no
that was that was complete nonsense when
I just said okay um how do I play here
Bishop should be seven problem to have
six ok his Bishop here on d3 is not
playing yet that's the only thing that's
kind of saving me can give this check it
doesn't help much now let's get the rock
over okay so he wants to go Bishop to g5
okay but I have this check so maybe this
is some kind of counter play
for d3 I don't know I'm just gambling
him might just be complete rubbish yeah
he's just taking it but the check
where's he going to d 1 I can actually
take here right this is not bad right he
blundered I was really lucky in this
game here so going here I wasn't it
absolutely terrible shape and now I'm a
piece up it's still a bit tricky but
anyway okay Bishop g7 that's what he
wants to do I guess
tricky i can go to age 50 let's do that
and Bishop t6 is also still kind of
annoying yes yes is check there but
okay I have no time I can take it seven
no we can take you seven you can take e
seven so what a shame okay maybe I can
still do something my porn is dangerous
it is dangerous I didn't see that
uh.okay Nanook t5o that we both played
this really really badly empty five ah
wow that was a terribly bad game poo
yeah first he was winning that I was
winning and and then i blundered it back
again okay guys let's see if them some
the stone in the background what's the
stone in the background the speaker ok I
hope you enjoyed this this show it will
serve over in the breeze one hour and
five minutes went past really really
quickly yeah with tactics i mean the
solving puzzles looking at positions um
yeah people played the c5 line in the
Bishop f4 qtg against me a bit um but I
don't know well there was this one game
where Magnus played this early rookie a
gem um an interesting idea but I don't
know it's not a super popular line
anyway the to dgs black I don't get it
so often and very often people play
Knight bd7 which is a bit more in
fashion somehow so i don't i don't
really know it's there's nothing
particularly wrong with c5 anyway never
was so I don't know people people can
play that without any problem ok guys
thanks for watching hope you liked it
and
I'm off for tonight yeah bye